on va commencer parce que peut-être que
je crois qu'on a je crois je crains
qu'on est un tout petit peu de retard
quelques minutes voilà on est très très
heureux d'être avec vous ce soir cette
première table ronde a lieu dans le
cadre de notre université de rentrée
dont le thème est la reconstruction au
fond reconstruire le pays et pour
reconstruire le pays nous disons qu'il
faut construire le centre solidifier le
centre unir le centre et c'est pour ça
que je suis extrêmement heureuse de
d'accueillir ici ce soir sous vos
applaudissements Jean Arthuis
qui est celui-ci à double titre
c'est lui parce qu'on va parler du
centre donc il est président l'Alliance
centriste chez lui parce qu'il est élu
député européen du Grand Ouest de la
France et donc on est très très heureux
de l'avoir avec nous et puis il est venu
avec Philippe folio je vous demande
d'applaudir
lui-même est en personne Jean-Jacques
j'égout c'est ça que tu le montre bravo
Jean-Jacques tu peux nous rejoindre
aussi je sais pas sur les genoux de gens
la salle si tu veux non
bon je vous présente pas tous ceux qui
m'entourent ici ce soir on va essayer de
débattre pendant une heure sur au fond
ben voilà oui pourquoi il faut François
la vie très très rapidement tout à
l'heure mais c'est une évidence il faut
rassembler il faut unir ce centre et si
le centre doit peser et changer la vie
politique française et être au fond la
famille la force politique qui peut
demain incarner un espoir et bien il est
vital qu'il se rassemblent inévitable
qu'il s'unissent qu'il se réunissent
qu'il continue de le faire pour peser
pour changer pour apporter l'espoir
nouveau dans la France a besoin c'est
aussi simple que cela cherchent je suis
très contente de vous passer la parole
en premier vous allez ouvrir notre débat
vous êtes notre invité on est très
heureux de vous avoir on est très
heureux de l'avoir avec nous à l'Europe
je dis ça nous Robert Nathalie et moi
dans notre délégation au Parlement
européen nous avons fait une liste
commune on en a été très heureux aux
élections européennes et on fait du bon
travail là-bas devant là-bas préside la
commission des budgets qui est une des
commissions les plus importantes du
Parlement européen et on est très
heureux et très fier de ce qu'il fait
avec nous la parole est à vous cherchons
merci Marielle merci François de m'avoir
invité à prendre part à cette soirée à
ce débat
et j'ai répondu immédiatement
positivement à ton invitation
je souhaitais venir vers vous parce que
en effet l'urgence est de rassembler la
famille
nous avons une histoire commune
nous avons eu des moments de crispation
des moments de séparation des moments
d'incompréhension mais
nous avons les mêmes valeurs
je crois que nous avons la même vision
et que
le projet que nous voulons porter
est inspiré par
le même désir de remettre l'État à sa
place de sortir la vie politique
des travers dans lesquels elle est
tombée
nos concitoyens n'en peuvent plus
de cette mise en scène permanente
des jeux politiciens
où chacun
procède par annonce
au risque d'afficher bien vite son
impuissance politique qui exaspère nos
concitoyens
et j'ai pu vérifier cette cette grande
proximité
à l'occasion des élections européennes
j'ai été Sénateur pendant quelques
années
et j'estimais que
les convictions européennes
me faisait obligation de tenter de
devenir
député européen
et nous sommes entrés en campagne
et nous avons tous compris à l'UDI comme
au modem
que nous ne pouvions exister
dans notre relation avec les Français
quand nous présentons ensemble
et je suis heureux de retrouver mes
collègues
députés européens du modèle mais nous
sommes membres du même groupe politique
et du même parti le Parti démocrate
européen
et pendant cette campagne
j'ai été en relation bien sûr dans le
grand Ouest dans les trois régions que
sont la Bretagne
les Pays de la Loire et le
Poitou-Charentes avec les militants de
l'UDI mais aussi avec ceux du MoDem
et je voudrais ce soir vous remercier
car
j'ai ressenti le même enthousiasme la
même ardeur chez les militants du MoDem
comme chez ceux de l'UDI et c'est aussi
pour ça que je suis venu ce soir
nous ne pourrons
peser dans la vie politique française
que si nous nous rassemblons
je suis
nous sommes condamné à la marginalité
si nous nous séparons
nous avons les mêmes valeurs
l'humanisme nous voulons nous sommes
suffisamment libéraux pour croire en
entreprise
et nos conditions sociales nous savons
qu'elles ne sont crédibles que s'il y a
une véritable réussite économique et une
vraie compétitivité nous faisons le même
diagnostic
l'État-providence est en faillite
et le modèle français ne peut pas être
prolongé
ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui est
pathétique
comme si on ne voulait toucher à rien
à rien
le risque de mettre chaque jour un peu
plus d'hommes et de femmes au chômage
et de maintenir un bon niveau
d'indemnisation du chômage
et tout cela financé par des déficits
publics
au prix d'un endettement qui ne cesse de
progresser
elle est publique était à peine à 20% du
PIB en 1980 elle va être maintenant à
100% du PIB la tendance est vertigineuse
nous avons la même conviction que tout
projet pour la France doit être
impérativement heureux compatible
et que sans définit le temps nous
pouvait prolonger l'illusion que nos
chefs d'État et gouvernement
je pouvais accréditer qu'il
que la France était encore souveraine or
aujourd'hui on le voit bien dans la
situation internationale avant d'où les
moyens de notre souveraineté en matière
diplomatique en matière
militaire par rapport aux géants du
numérique l'Europe est devenue une
colonie du numérique
Google Amazon Netflix
font ce qu'ils veulent
et ils sont tellement puissants qu'il
parviennent même par David optimisation
fiscale un pas payer d'impôts sur
l'ensemble du territoire européen donc
nous voyons bien que nos souverainetés
nous ne pourrons les assumer que si nous
les partageons
et nous devons les partager et les
assumer comme tel au plan européen
c'est pour ça que nous avons des
conditions européennes c'est pour nous
permettre de reprendre notre destin en
main
nous sommes dans la mondialisation il
est 20 de pleurer sur la globalisation
elle est là irréversible c'est le sens
du phénomène humain et si nous voulons
participer à l'organisation du monde
mieux vaut y aller ensemble au plan
européen
et on voit bien que la crise qui nous
atteint n'est pas seulement économique
sociale
politique cette incapacité
à faire des réformes concrètes les
discours sont extraordinaires
Valls se fait du fait du Sarkozy
ça veut dire que on arrive à fâcher les
gens qui ont l'impression qu'on fait de
l'austérité alors qu'on a rien qu'on n'a
rien fait pratiquement et qu'on a rien
bougé
donc ceci ne peut pas continuer et je
pense que notre famille a une place à
reprendre et pour l'occuper il faut
qu'elle soit rassemblée
rassembler toute la famille centrée
c'est peut-être au-delà au-delà
je découvre à Bruxelles et je voudrais
rendre hommage à Marielle qui la
présidente de la délégation française au
sein du groupe ADL
et je la remercie pour
les facilités qu'elle m'a donné qui
m'ont permis de devenir président de
la commission des budgets au Parlement
européen
ce qui m'a empêché d'être candidat à la
présidente de l'udio
que les députés européens français ont
quelquefois du mal
à s'impliquer totalement en dehors de
ceux qui sont ici à cette tribune ce
soir
et de ceux qui ont été élus comme udi
que j'ai pensé que mon devoir était de
m'investir totalement dans l'exercice de
ce mandat de député européen c'est pour
ça que j'ai je me suis débit de mes
fonctions de Président du Conseil
Général de la Mayenne on va consacré à
plein à l'exercice de ce mandat
et essayer de le faire bouger un peu la
bulle parce que on peut pas dire que les
élections européennes n'est pas été
d'une sévérité extrême
où est le lien citoyen
de mettre sur votre passeport République
française Union européenne
si on juge
la densité du lien citoyen
au travers des élections du 25 mai
et la matière à s'inquiéter entre les
abstentions les votes europhobe les
votes euro-sceptiques
ceux qui ont vraiment envie de
construire l'Europe
elles sont pas sont pas si nombreux et
ça ne va pas être simple alors je pense
que nous d'autons avoir un projet pour
la France qui est forcément un projet
euro compatible ça veut dire que sur ce
que j'appelle les prérogatifs de
souveraineté nationale il faut nous
préparer à donner à l'Europe un vrai
pilotage politique et cessé d'en faire
une sorte d'intercommunalité qui
fonctionne pas bien parce que chaque
mère veut garder ses prérogatives par
rapport à la communauté de communes ou
par rapport à la communauté
d'agglomération et il faut également que
l'on se prépare à faire converger nos
législations sociales fiscales dans le
droit du travail
nos règles environnementales
au fond si j'ai souhaité quitter le
Sénat et c'est parce que sur un certain
nombre de textes de loi de projet de loi
est apparu qu'en matière économique en
matière financière quand on légiférait
un échelon infra-européen
on était dans la communication
on était dans la gesticulation
on faisait des lois qu'il ne peut pas
avoir d'applications concrètes
et en matière économique comme en
matière financière et en matière
environnementale on ne peut avoir
d'impact qu'à l'échelon européen
et donc le parlement national devenait
sur ses lois
fondamentales en quelque sorte un office
notarial s'il y a parmi vous des
notaires qui ne le prennent pas mauvaise
part où l'on transcrivait
des directives qui étaient conçues et
voter par le Parlement européen et donc
vous avez compris que je souhaitais
aller à la source du droit
en devenant députés européens mais ce
soir je suis très heureux de partager ce
moment avec vous ça n'est pas ma
première participation François aux
universités d'été
du modèle
mais je voulais vous dire que pour moi
l'urgence c'est de rassembler toute la
famille centriste
et c'est l'intérêt de la France
merci beaucoup beaucoup agent on va vous
allez reprendre la parole on va essayer
de débattre des dialoguer entre nous
entre la salle de vous écouter de vous
entendre
mais je veux dire que au-delà même de
rassembler la famille centriste que vous
dites qui est juste
je pense que jamais probablement
l'espace n'aoté aussi grand pour le
centre que nous représentons ici ce soir
jamais au fond l'attente des Français
d'une autre
d'une autre alternative d'un choix
différent de ce qu'ils connaissent
depuis 30 ans n'a été aussi fort et au
fond si le centre est en capacité de
s'unir de rassembler et de peser c'est
la seule façon aussi de faire baisser
dans ce pays l'extrême droite et
alternatif qui est en train de naître de
ce côté-là et la seule réponse au fond
au Front national
c'est de représenter nous-mêmes
l'alternative d'incarner ce que nous
avons commencé de construire il y a un
an je crois que jamais les thèses les
thèmes les idées les idéaux qui ont été
les nôtres et qui sont les nôtres depuis
des années ne sont au fond aussi attendu
par les Français sur des questions
d'éthique François sur les questions de
moralisation de la vie publique sur la
question de changement des institutions
dont tout le monde voit bien à quel
point elles sont vitales essentielles
oui il faut qu'on ait un parlement qui
ressemble à la France oui il faut qu'on
ait un vrai équilibre dans le pouvoir
parlementaire peut-être un jour une
décision comme nous avons nous au
Parlement européen oui donc il faut un
changement nos institutions oui il faut
respecter les règles en matière de
déficit et de dette oui il faut dire la
vérité au peuple oui il faut que les
entreprises puissent entreprendre créer
oui il faut libérer tout cela oui il
faut repenser la solidarité
oui il faut redonner de la liberté il
faut redonner de la responsabilité il
faut donner davantage sur le terrain on
entendait tout à l'heure qui nous
parlait au fond de toutes ces lois qui
leur tomber comme toi comme si tous les
territoires étaient les mêmes
comme si tous les territoires étaient
les mêmes dans toute la France et on
voit bien que là aussi nous avons nous
une autre manière de penser en faisant
davantage confiance au territoire de
recréer des solidarités différentes de
repenser aussi au fond le domaine de
l'action publique et le domaine de la
dépense publique de revoir son
efficacité bref je fais la liste là mais
on pourrait la compléter de tout ce que
nous disons depuis des années et qui au
fond je le crois correspond aux attentes
des Français et donc je pense que nous
avons une responsabilité très importante
c'est pas juste au fond pour le bonheur
ou le plaisir d'être ensemble que nous
devons faire les choses on doit les
faire aussi pour notre pays c'est
simplement cela que je voulais ajouter à
ce que j'en viens de dire
Yann est-ce que je te passe maintenant
un micro tu nous dis quelques mots et
puis ensuite ce que j'aimerais c'est que
les micros circulent dans la salle que
vous interveniez les trois quatre qui
veulent intervenir vous vous situez un
peu dans la salle vous levez les mains
vous réfléchissez on vous passe le micro
et puis on revient ensuite vers la
tribune à toi Yann très rapidement
d'abord je voulais vous informer que ce
n'était pas mon anniversaire ce soir
semble être une information importante à
vous donner
il y en a qu'un qui a son anniversaire à
cette tribune ce soir faudra deviner
mais bon
plus sérieusement moi je vais rapidement
dire de petites choses c'est que
c'est des sentiments que j'ai de
perception que j'ai autour de moi c'est
que il y a effectivement comme la Dijon
Arthur et Marielle de sarnaise
un boulevard une étendue de d'attente
vis-à-vis d'une vis-à-vis d'autres
choses et de nous peut-être mais en tout
cas vis-à-vis d'autres choses
cette étendu elle est quand même
aujourd'hui elle se reflète elle se
traduit par un marasme extraordinaire
dans la population et moi je note dans
mon entourage j'expliquais aujourd'hui
que à table quand je avec mes collègues
de travail on se retrouve en débattait
politique jusqu'à il y a pas longtemps
et en débat plus politique parce que ça
ne nous intéresse plus il y a un
désintérêt aujourd'hui un des intérêts
importants par rapport évidemment au
pouvoir en place avec
un pouvoir socialiste qui gère le Parti
socialiste avant de gérer le pays
on le voit tous les jours dans les
arbitrages qui sont faits et puis ce
sentiment que
pas seulement des nouvelles du jour
d'aujourd'hui même mais ce sentiment que
et bien on est sur un regard dans le
rétroviseur on nous rejoue les mêmes
épisodes que ceux qu'on a déjà connu et
ça les gens n'en veulent pas les gens
sont fatigués de ça les gens veulent
autre chose et ce et ce besoin d'autre
chose aujourd'hui il est impérieux qu'il
s'incarne et qu'il se traduisent quelque
part d'autres que du côté du parc
socialiste ou de côté de ce qu'on
perçoit se construire aujourd'hui et qui
finalement n'est rien d'autre que ce
qu'on a déjà vu que par le passé
l'histoire se répète mais les gens n'en
veulent plus ils n'y croient plus ils ne
veulent plus de ça donc bien entendu
qu'on a besoin nous d'offrir quelque
chose
j'allais j'allais parce que c'est écrit
sur mon front vous dire aussi que
j'étais il y a quelques semaines aux
universités d'été des vers alors
invitation ce qui était une première
c'est la preuve qui vont pas bien quand
il m'invite c'est qu'ils vont pas bien
pour vous dire que là-bas aussi dans
cette sphère politique là qui n'est pas
si loin à thème de que ça de nous il y a
aussi beaucoup de questions il y a
beaucoup d'interrogations une histoire
qui s'est déroulée et qui aujourd'hui
arrive à sa fin et qui cherchent autre
chose qui cherche une nouvelle histoire
et cette nouvelle histoire c'est aussi à
nous de l'écrire merci beaucoup Yann
est-ce qu'on fait un aller-retour sur la
salle qui veut s'exprimer
vas-y
chacun se présente ou chacune se
présente voilà bonjour Patrick
j'avais juste une réflexion par rapport
à la reconstruction de la France parce
que là dans les dans les discours
j'entends beaucoup de il faut et on
aimerait qu'il faudrait faire ceci cela
malheureusement je ne je n'entends que
très très rarement des verbes d'action
et des solutions concrètes pour
atteindre ses objectifs
donc c'était juste pour poser la
question est-ce que est-ce que le MoDem
se donne les moyens de ces objectifs que
ça soit pour le modem ou pour la France
la bonne question parce qu'évidemment il
y a besoin d'action et plus de parole ça
on est tous d'accord Robert Jean allez-y
bien ben oui c'est concret un
anniversaire donc merci
oui je crois que
c'est pas facile il a dit hier
non mais fallait la faire j'ai le droit
aujourd'hui j'ai le droit c'est dur non
je voudrais je voudrais commencer par ta
question
je vais peut-être te surprendre mais je
pense effectivement que sortir notre
pays de la crise va être quelque chose
de très difficile et c'est pour cela que
d'ailleurs
refonder reconstruire la société
française et reconstruire et refonder le
centre c'est la même chose parce que ce
que nous voyons finalement c'est que le
jeu politique classique ne permet plus
de reconstruire notre pays et il faut
que en quelques secondes on soit
conscient de ce qui a été le piège dans
lequel François Hollande est tombé il
est tombé dans un piège qui a consisté à
se laisser porter par une vague
démagogique consistant à dire je vais
faire le contraire de ce que le
président précédent a fait et quand on
fait ça on laisse croire effectivement
aux Français qu'il suffira de faire le
contraire pour que et du coup on se on
est obligé de de d'amener l'idée que la
la réponse ça va être rapide et que les
choses vont aller mieux comment dire
rapidement et on est pris parce que Jean
tout à l'heure appelait finalement son
extrême ou ce que l'on pourrait appeler
une fausse idéologie des choses et des
slogans ou des vieilles recettes ce que
je voudrais en aucun cas c'est que la
prochaine alternance soit de même nature
que celle-là mais dans l'autre sens
parce que si ça devait se produire comme
ça alors je vous dis que quel que soit
celui qui porterait le pouvoir qui
serait qui arriverait au pouvoir il
referait les mêmes erreurs en symétrique
que les erreurs que François Hollande a
pu commettre et qui peut commettre
depuis deux ans c'est pour cela que nous
avons une responsabilité extrêmement
particulière et extrêmement forte qui
est non pas de vouloir casser la façon
classique de faire de la politique parce
que les gens se retrouveraient plus dans
l'image des politiques ou dans une façon
d'un discours qui est décalé de la
réalité mais tout simplement parce que
c'est une nécessité vitale pour inventer
des solutions nouvelles pour sortir
notre pays des difficultés dans
lesquelles dans lesquelles il se trouve
parce que si je prends un exemple simple
la gauche nous dit est fait tous les
jours quelque chose qui est finalement
sa vieille recette qui est de la dépense
publique j'ai été très choquée
d'ailleurs dans la conférence de presse
du Président hier par cette phrase qui
pour moi était très grave quand il a dit
je vais vous dire ce que je dirais à
Bruxelles pour faire passer mon plan je
vais vous le dire comme une confidence
je vais leur dire qu'on ne peut pas à la
fois améliorer la compétitivité de notre
pays et en même temps réduire la dépense
publique et on va d'abord s'engager sur
le premier point et on fera le second
que plus tard ce qui est totalement faux
de mon point de vue parce que la
compétitivité de notre pays peut-être
restaurer par bien d'autres méthodes que
celles qui consiste à dégager de
l'argent public soit pour réduire les
charges des entreprises soit pour
financer des plans qui seraient
susceptibles de ramener de la croissance
par tout un tas de mesures y compris les
mesures
la façon de refonder le travail la
flexibilité au travail etc donc ça c'est
déjà quelque chose qui me semble tout à
fait inexact de le dire comme ça mais ça
montrait d'une certaine façon et au-delà
du clin d'oeil je crois qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui correspondait à
quelque chose qui est profond dans son
camp que et comme ça avait été annoncé
la semaine passée d'ailleurs on
désertait une fois de plus l'exigence de
travailler sur la réduction effective de
la dépense publique et je voudrais pas
que de l'autre côté comment dire dans
deux ans ou dans deux ans et demi ou
dans trois ans la droite arrive en
disant nous allons réduire les dépenses
publiques et tout sera réglé du jour au
lendemain parce que ce ne sera pas vrai
parce que nous avons une maladie en
France qui est cette dépendance que nous
avons à l'état qui fait que nous avons
construit un état qui ne s'être efficace
aujourd'hui que quand il est cher et
quand il a un peu moins d'argent il ne
sait même plus être efficace du tout et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation où l'État continue à être trop
cher et ou en même temps il y a de moins
en moins efficace et vous le savez
partout parce que quand on supprime des
postes de fonctionnaires sans changer
les façons d'agir de l'État et bien on
bloque encore plus l'état et donc nous
avons un vrai devoir et pourquoi c'est
la question du centre je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est la question du centre
c'est la question du centre parce que il
va falloir
réinventer tout simplement des façons
non seulement de gérer la société mais
d'inciter la société à se gérer
elle-même et par exemple parce que les
centristes sont la femme représente la
famille politique et la famille
politique qui préfère le pragmatisme à
l'idéologie qui préfère le local
remontant au National descendants
parce que c'est une famille politique et
capable de comprendre que par exemple si
on veut réduire les dépenses publiques
sur une question précise et bien si on
regarde ce qui se passe concrètement sur
le terrain si on fait des comparaisons
si on fait dans ce mot franglais qui est
utilisé dans les entreprises tous les
jours du benchmarking c'est à dire si on
dit tiens comment dans tel endroit on a
fait aussi bien voir mieux en dépensant
moins cher avec ce type de méthode et
bien si on le fait là on arrivera à
faire en sorte que on réduise la dépense
publique sans réduire le pacte social
qui est celui qui unit notre société et
sans pour autant être en contradiction
avec la compétitivité que notre pays
doit retrouver et bien voyez on aura
réussi le coup et ça moi je crois qu'il
y a toute une ingénierie nouvelle de la
société de l'articulation entre la
politique et la société civile la
société économique et nous sommes les
seuls
à pouvoir inventer cela nous sommes les
seuls à pouvoir inventer cela parce que
effectivement pour faire simple j'espère
que le jour nous serons au pouvoir on
changera pas juste de promotion de l'ENA
pour penser qu'on réglera tous les
problèmes à la fois en passant de la
promotion Voltaire à une autre promotion
et ce qui m'a également étonné dans le
dans le discours du président de la
République hier c'est que finalement on
avait le sentiment qu'il avait tout
épuisé des méthodes qui étaient censées
être les siennes et qu'il était là en
train de nous dire on attend les
résultats on espère que les résultats
vont arriver avant 2017 ou après 2017 je
ne sais pas certains observateurs ont
trouvé que bon c'était peut-être pas
habile de sa part de mettre le curseur
sur 2017 par rapport aux résultats parce
que les Françaises qui veulent c'est par
rapport à leurs échéances à eux-mêmes et
pas par rapport à l'échange électorale
et c'est ça que nous avons à faire et
nous avons à faire quelque chose qui est
de remettre les gens en confiance avec
eux-mêmes quand on dit qu'il y a une
crise de confiance dans la société Ken
crise de défiance oui c'est une crise de
confiance des citoyens par rapport aux
institutions dans tous les domaines mais
c'est pire que ça aujourd'hui c'est une
crise de confiance des citoyens avec
eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire nous avons à faire
comprendre qu'on repartant par le bas en
repartant par la confiance donnée je
termine juste né par une anecdote et
j'en ai terminé là
vous savez qu'il y a et au Parlement
européen nous avons travaillé un tout
petit peu cette semaine puisque nous
revenons de Strasbourg sur l'initiative
jeune vous savez cette cette très belle
idée qui consiste à dire en Europe plus
jamais un jeune totalement inactivité au
bout de quatre mois il faut qu'il soit
en formation qualification ou bien qu'il
est retrouvé un emploi la France se
vantant d'ailleurs d'avoir été à
l'origine de cette initiative et en même
temps
d'être le premier pays qui a signé avec
Bruxelles la condition d'application
pour notre territoire français de cette
garantie jeune et tout à l'heure je
crois que c'était à table donc c'était
pas ici j'en disais que de toute façon
il y avait pas d'argent pour faire vivre
cette réalité mais au-delà de ça
comme j'ai travaillé un tout petit peu
là dessus j'ai pris j'ai vu la note que
la France a préparé justement pour
expliquer comment cette initiative jeune
allait être mise en place en France là
où il y a un petit peu d'argent quand
même pour les mettre en place c'est
désespérant j'étais mais totalement
désespéré quand je lui souhaite note la
mise en place en France de l'initiative
jeune avec le peu d'argent qu'on a ça
consiste à faire la même chose que ce
qu'on fait depuis 20 ans depuis 30 ans
c'est à dire la même chose c'est ces
stages non qualifiants ces stages
destinés à ce que les jeunes ne soient
plus inscrits à Pôle emploi pendant
qu'ils font le stage ces stages comment
dire qui sont par rappel d'offres
données à des entreprises qui font à peu
près tout et n'importe quoi simplement
pour occuper les gens et bien
l'application en France de cette
initiative jeune c'est rien d'autre que
ça avec 10% de plus ou 20% de plus j'en
ai été consterné donc tout à l'heure
nous avons eu un très bon débat ici
animé par
excuse-moi de chercher ton nom de
seconde Jean-Pierre Riou qui parlait qui
parlait des questions de de fracture et
en tout cas moi je pense que pour
réparer les fractures de la société
française il va falloir qu'on amène des
ruptures et les ruptures c'est dans la
façon dont nous devons comment dire
concevoir l'action et faire cette action
et je crois qu'on est les seuls à
pouvoir le faire autrement parce que on
est les seuls à pouvoir éviter ce que
j'ai dit au début et ce par le quoi je
vais terminer c'est à dire cette espèce
de tournée manège qui est un piège
absolu parce que finalement d'un coup
sur l'autre on part du principe que on
va faire l'inverse de ce que fait
l'autre on dit aux français qu'on va
avoir des résultats on les trompe
complètement et on change rien dans le
fond au système parce qu'on continue à
partir d'en haut on continue comment
dire à écraser les réalités humaines et
sociales on continue à côté de la plaque
et on est complice de la souffrance et
du drame social qui aujourd'hui vécu de
plus en plus dans notre pays
merci beaucoup
merci Robert je donne la parole pour
quelques phrases agents en complément et
ensuite je vous promets je reviens vers
vous non non agent Arthuis qui voulait
la parole je reviens vers vous dans la
salle il y a au moins 5 6 bras levés
donc on revient vers vous tout de suite
et on reviendra après sur la tribune la
pédagogie et la rhétorique
gouvernementale il y a un an les
gouvernements français allemands ont dit
en même temps nous allons baisser la
dépense publique de 10 milliards
et le ministre allemand a dit voilà nous
dépensions 350 milliards nous avons
dépenser 340 le ministre français a dit
nous dépensions 350 nous avons dépensé
on y attend on voudrait comprendre parce
que 360 ça fait 10 milliards de plus oui
mais si j'étais pas là on aurait dépensé
370 donc
on se raconte des histoires en
permanence et il va falloir qu'on
commence à articuler des propositions
maintenant
pouvons-nous continuer
pouvons-nous continuer par exemple si
vous voulez réduire la dépense publique
pouvons-nous continuer avec les 35
heures dans la fonction publique moi je
ne le crois pas
souvenez-vous lorsque les 35 heures ont
été conçus c'était pour le secteur
marchand on allait répartir en un plus
grand nombre de personnes le travail en
réduisant la durée de son travail mais
ça ne devait pas s'appliquer à la
fonction publique au 1 an plus tard on
l'appliquait aux trois fonctions
publiques et bien moi je pense qu'on ne
pourra pas tenir si on maintient ce
standard il faudra avoir le courage
d'expliquer cela à nos concitoyens sinon
on y parviendrons pas il faudra par
ailleurs que l'innovation ne soit pas
réservée aux seuls marchand on doit
pouvoir innover également dans le
secteur public dans la façon de répondre
à la tente de nos concitoyens pourquoi
voulez-vous que telle politique de
service public soit la même dans le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais dans
Poitou-Charentes dans le Midi dans la
Mayenne ou dans le Morbihan je pense
qu'il faut laisser des possibilités
d'adaptation et d'innovation
et que on arrête de définir par le menu
les standards les critères les corsets
ceci ne peut plus durer on est dans une
hystérie normative qui fait qu'on
n'arrive plus à supporter la charge et
on est dans un pays qui donne
l'impression d'honneur rien vouloir
changer parce qu'on a des standards
sociaux un modèle social qui est
formidable on ne le change pas il y aura
de moins en moins de gens à travailler
et on voudra maintenir un haut niveau
d'indemnisation de ceux qui sont
chômeurs ceux-ci n'est possible qu'avec
un déficit croissant et un endettement
public croissant donc c'est le but
absolu et quand on dit que c'est
l'Europe qui nous donne l'austérité très
franchement mes amis s'il n'y avait pas
l'Europe on aurait été mis en demeure
instantanément par ceux qui nous
prennent de l'argent et plus la moitié
des bons du Trésor sont souscrits par
des investisseurs étrangers et bien on
aurait été mis en demeure d'équilibrer
nos comptes publics sauf à payer des
taux d'intérêt très élevés donc nous
avons un devoir de réalisme et le centre
doit être l'éclaireur le pédagogue la
lucidité et le courage
merci Georges
on revient vers vous alors vas-y
Jean-Baptiste plusieurs
si chacun est pas trop long mais nous
aussi il faut effectivement qu'on fasse
attention pour tout le monde puisse tous
ceux qui veulent s'exprimer puissent
s'exprimer on va prendre plusieurs
interventions vas-y oui vous vous
présentez à chaque fois
James George de Lyon j'ai traversé la
France pour être ce soir avec vous et
poser ma question
oui
alors je suis pour de la vérité en
politique et je pense que c'est
l'occasion de se dire les choses et je
suis pour qu'on se dise des choses
cet après-midi j'ai lu Le Figaro il y a
Emmanuel galiro du Figaro qui a rapporté
les propos et l'interview de François
et sa volonté de vouloir sortir des
Bermudes du Triangle des Bermudes fondé
pour
par rapport à l'UMP le PS et le Front
national alors moi j'aimerais par
rapport à ça poser quelques questions
rapides comment
comment croire aujourd'hui
à cette volonté alors que notre
endettement va atteindre 100% du PIB
alors c'est dénoncé depuis France par
François depuis très longtemps
alors que pendant la campagne européenne
il n'a pas soutenu son idée de modéliser
les dettes souveraines qu'il avait
notamment présenté sur un plateau On
n'est pas couché
comment croire à cette volonté de sortir
des triangles et Bermudes alors que par
rapport à certains sujets et je rejoins
ce que disait Jean Arthuis à un instant
par rapport à la question du commerce
que vous n'ayez pas soutenu
le contre le projet transatlantique TIPP
ttip pardon
donnant plus de pouvoir aux sociétés
transnationales et aux multinationales
comme vous le savez au détriment des
peuples
et c'est pour ça qu'on soutient pas
cette idée enfin juste pour clarifier
remettre à l'endroit ce que tu viens de
dire voilà continue merci vous non vous
la soutenez pas mais on ne soutient pas
l'idée de tribunaux arbitraux
supranationaux qui interviennent contre
la volonté qui peut être celle de pays
membres de l'Union européenne non nous
ne soutenons pas cette idée là
encore maintenant comment croire cette
volonté de sortir de l'UMP du PS et du
Front national alors que l'UDI et je
m'adresse argentuit a déclaré que ils
étaient la liée naturelle de l'UMP et
puis enfin comment croire François
Bayrou dire ça alors que
alors qu'en 2007 Ségolène Royal lui a
attendu la main pour créer une
redistribution du pouvoir central par
rapport à une sociale sociale
libéralisme et qui n'a pas saisi à cette
occasion merci merci beaucoup à toi on
fait circuler
donnez-nous ça c'est ça qu'on attend
tous sur le terrain et on va gagner ok
merci beaucoup allez on en prend encore
deux autres et puis après on revient on
revient chez nous
oui des femmes ça serait cool ça c'est
sûr
ah il y a une femme ici au deuxième rang
allez hop
vas-y
de Paris moi je voudrais
je voudrais recentrer la question sur le
débat c'est-à-dire construire la France
je m'adresse à notre belle proche
brochette de députée européenne
François nous dit souvent et il a
entièrement raison évidemment
que les problèmes ne viennent pas
d'ailleurs mais de la France et
certainement pas de l'Europe alors je
voudrais savoir dans ce projet de
reconstruction de la France vous députés
européens
quel serait les mesures qui seraient
possible en fait d'envisager pour aider
la France à reconstruire cette France
justement merci beaucoup alors on va non
je vais revenir un tout petit peu sur la
tribune et puis je repars sur la salle
alors Jean tu as été en plus appelé
demander attendu espérer et donc la
parole est à toi
merci
de répondre à cette question
d'abord je voudrais
vous remercier parce qu'ici même l'an
dernier
vous m'avez procuré un des plus grands
moments d'émotion de ma vie
à un moment où je l'étais aussi
particulièrement et je n'ai pas oublié
ce que voilà ce que vous m'avez réservé
ce soir là je voulais très simplement
vous le dire
je voudrais dire aussi et François a dit
tout à l'heure que j'ai eu le bonheur de
débarquer je dis le bonheur parce que ça
faisait longtemps que j'attendais qu'il
se passe quelque chose qui sorte de
l'ordinaire d'arriver chez vous au
moment où démarrer
votre fabuleuse histoire de bonnets
rouges
et j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire puis
sur cette époque là j'ai été
relativement écouté j'ai dit mais je
suis tout sauf surpris
et je ne l'avais je l'étais d'autant
moins que j'étais monté le 17 juin à
Paris j'avais remis une note à la
surprise qui n'avait pas eu le temps de
me recevoir Monsieur le Président de
l'Assemblée nationale m'avait reçu 50
minutes je lui ai expliqué c'était
accompagné de Christophe lorik
et lorsque je l'avais quitté il m'avait
dit tu vois j'étais accordé 10 minutes
de plus que ce que j'avais prévu
et pourquoi et je montais alors que je
marchais c'est pas ce que ce que
j'entendais à travers toute la France
me laisser penser que nous n'étions pas
loin
d'événements que nous n'avions que moi
personnellement je n'avais pas connu
quand un patron un responsable de
syndicats une mère de famille un chômeur
un jeune qui travaille au pas disent
tous la même chose
au pays de la lutte des glaces c'est
qu'il y a quand même quelque chose qui
se passe et au fond j'ai pas été étonné
qu'une fois de plus
ce soit chez vous que ça se cristallise
et François a rendu hommage à Monsieur
le Maire de carré je voudrais le faire
aussi mais rendre hommage aussi à
l'esprit de responsabilité
exceptionnelle qui a été le vôtre parce
que si vous n'aviez pas reporté votre
troisième réunion de moi
époque à laquelle généralement rongeant
on rentre chez soi pour fêter Noël
et bien c'est le pays tout entier qui
s'embrasait et qui s'embrasait dans
l'esprit dans lequel vous l'aviez voulu
parce que je vous ai beaucoup écouté
j'ai eu beaucoup de réunions où il y
avait des pour il y avait des contre et
j'ai vu la capacité que vous saviez à
vous en parle et je pense que
ce que vous avez fait
nous sommes à la veille de leur
reconnaître je suis pas sûr 2017 je
pense que je ne crois pas que nous
vivrons 2017 tel que nous l'imaginons ou
alors il y a quelque chose qui m'a
échappé et que je n'ai pas compris
je voudrais dire ensuite que bon il n'y
a pas que les mauvaises nouvelles
à l'âge que j'ai maintenant et avec ce
qui sont là sont venus du site nous
avons vécu le plus beau le plus bel
accomplissement de rêve de notre vie
François est devenu mère de Pau
personne
de tout ce qui le mettait plus bas que
terre
quelques semaines auparavant n'a plus
posé la question de savoir qu'il était
avec qui il était et pour commencer à se
faisait ils ont voté à
63%. contre l'un des plus grandes barons
qui montent du PS et ils l'ont fait dans
une ville qui ne l'avait plus fait
depuis 40 ans
voilà
et comme je sais qu'il y a le nombre
coéquipiers de François je ne pouvais
pas m'empêcher d'avoir cette petite
pensée et je j'en profite pour remercier
ceux qui d'entre vous m'avez invité j'ai
fait une vingtaine de campagnes
électorales pendant cette courte période
et je suis venu à d'autres fois chez
vous et j'ai eu le bonheur d'apprendre
que pratiquement toutes les écuries que
j'étais venues soutenir avec gagné alors
il y en a certainement quelques-unes et
merci beaucoup
comme un mari à la mi avait invité fait
elle avait suggéré un jour elle
m'accompagnait dans la marche
ainsi que une amie très ancienne que
j'aime beaucoup et comme tu l'as fait
mon cher Philippe toi qui était venu me
soutenir aussi alors que c'était
difficile aux régionales à Bordeaux
Marielle m'a dit mais ce serait bien que
nous poursuivions ce Tour de France par
un mini tour d'Europe pendant la
campagne électorale et je l'ai fait
et je croyais que ce que j'avais vécu en
France
c'était dur c'était brutal ça m'a
déstabilisé je disais tout à fait tout à
l'heure à François Bon je suis encore en
train de me remettre je vais essayer de
publier mon de bouquins je suis à
sa quatrième écriture
c'est vous dire si ça me paraît simple
parce que ce que je dois écrire je
voudrais qu'il fut lu par quelqu'un qui
n'a jamais lu un livre de sa vie mais
aussi par le président de l'Académie
française donc vous voyez c'est assez
difficile et j'ai vécu à ce moment-là
après avoir fait 15 pays
et pas que des capitales exactement
jean-marti le même sentiment que celui
que j'avais trouvé en France à une
différence près c'est qu'il n'y a pas
une famille Le Pen qui a pris racine en
Italie ou qui a pris racine en Roumanie
ou qui a pris racine mais en Grèce
et je voulais dire
c'est la différence mais j'étais étonné
parce que c'était exceptionnel des
jeunes de tout pays et de notamment
beaucoup de Français alors à Berlin un
rhum des
gens dans d'autres pays et ça ne posait
pas de problème un seul je n'en ai pas
trouvé un qui me dit qu'il allait voter
parce qu'il n'avait pas sa carte
électorale l'autre parce qu'il n'avait
pas prévu l'autre parce qu'il ne voulait
pas rentrer à ce moment-là et le dernier
parce qu'il
n'est pouvait aucune aucune aucune
aucune comme besoin voilà c'est le seul
élément mais j'ai beaucoup vu et
j'aurais pu donner des résultats ces
élections électorales à l'issue de ces
22 jours je ne sais pas comment je vais
arriver à traduire cela mais ça m'a
considérable marqué et pour ceux qui
pensent que le problème n'est que
français je pense que comme tu l'as dit
François plusieurs reprises il est à
peine un petit peu plus compliqué enfin
je voudrais dire que et Jean-Christophe
Loris s'exprimera là dessus demain et je
suis désolé parce que je suis obligé de
vous quitter le mince c'est pour ça je
suis un peu plus long mais demain
je serai avec vos par la pensée
tu demandais qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de
concret et
savoir répondu
moi je vais essayer de faire dans ce que
j'ai appris à peine un petit peu à faire
et que je sais encore très mal faire
c'est d'écouter les autres c'est
d'échanger lorsque la colère est tombée
c'est d'essayer de voir comment des
bonnets rouges et des antibonés rouges
peuvent faire mouvement aussi
exceptionnel qui a frappé la France et
bien au-delà de la France et je essayais
de voir s'il n'y a pas et si comme dans
l'esprit de France soit qui veut
reconstruire la France moi je disais je
voudrais essayer de contribuer à la
retaper retaper la France et bien s'il
n'y a pas effectivement des forces du
peuple que nous avons oublié le grand
oubliau du peuple depuis 25 ans c'est le
grand oublié de tous les débats de
toutes les discussions sortent de nous
il faut le dire les choses comme elles
sont c'est le peuple et il y a
certainement une ingénierie il y a
certainement une intelligence de la
relation l'intelligence de la
reconnaissance de celui de ce que fait
l'autre à mettre en œuvre je veux
essayer de m'y employer et comme vous
m'avez accompagné à travers toutes les
routes de France
et vous n'avez pas à regarder quels
étaient vos attentats j'ai là aussi dans
le cadre de la famille politique
François
besoins de vous et je vous remercie
merci Jean pour ce que tu dis évidemment
mais pour ce que tu es plus encore
Philippe Folliot je voudrais que tu
voilà prennes la parole maintenant vous
reconnaîtrez la difficulté de la tâche
de s'exprimer après Jean
je voudrais tout d'abord vous dire que
je suis particulièrement heureux d'être
parmi vous ce soir
me revienne en mémoire un certain nombre
d'aventures que nous avons connu plus
particulièrement en 2007 et en 2012 et
j'ai cette intime conviction qu'il est
important pour notre pays de faire de
telle sorte que dans les grands
rendez-vous démocratiques qui s'offrent
à nous pour les mois et les amener à
venir et bien que notre famille puisse
réunir rassembler comme la forge
justement dit Jean tout à l'heure se
retrouver parce que
dans un contexte que nous connaissons
avec un parti socialiste complètement
vous demande discrédité une UMP qui est
guère mieux et bien si nous n'existons
pas si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'incarner cette alternative et bien
nous ne laisserons à nos concitoyens que
la possibilité pour certaines de ce
retourner vers la gauche de la gauche et
pour les autres de se retourner vers la
droite de la droite et donc nous avons
une responsabilité qui est une
responsabilité morale une responsabilité
politique une responsabilité historique
de nous retrouver pour être à même de
pouvoir incarner cet espoir que le pays
attend alors pour cela il va falloir que
nous puissions nous retrouver mais il va
falloir aussi que nous fassions preuve
d'ouverture parce que notre famille
politique et bien elle incarne ce qui
est le contraire d'autres qui finalement
prône le repli sur soi Pr très tolérance
prône le rejet de l'autre et bien nous
nous incarnons l'ouverture à l'autre
nous incarnons l'idée et cette grande
idée européenne nous incarnons aussi
cette notion de respect et le fait que
finalement il n'y a pas que des bons
d'un côté que des mauvais de l'autre
mais que cette cette ligne Maginot qui a
certains égards traverse
artificiellement notre vie politique et
bien il faudra la faire sauter pour
faire de telle sorte que toutes celles
et ceux qui ont envie que les choses
changent qui ont envie que les choses
bougent et bien ne puissent se retrouver
et cela ne pourra se faire qu'autour de
nous
autour de nous
udi autour de nous modèle autour de nous
toutes celles et ceux qui ne se
retrouvent pas je veux dire dans le
Parti socialiste d'aujourd'hui ou dans
l'UMP d'aujourd'hui et vous pouvez
applaudir
et
au-delà au-delà de cela il faudra que
nous fassions preuve de courage de
courage pour dire aux françaises et aux
Français quelle est la situation du pays
comme François tu l'as fait en 2016
comme tu l'as fait en 2012 mais je crois
que au-delà de cela il va falloir aussi
que nous changions un certain nombre de
d'éléments de vision par rapport à notre
pays et ceux qui me paraît essentiel et
fondamental c'est que depuis plusieurs
décennies
droite-gauche confondues alternativement
ont chacune mené des politiques qui ont
été des politiques courtes et ceux qui
doit nous différencier nous par rapport
à eux c'est de tenir des propos par
rapport à nos concitoyens qui consiste à
dire nous avons un projet mais un projet
qui n'est pas d'inverser la courbe du
chômage pour les six mois qui viennent
de faire de telle sorte que le déficit
baisse pour les trois mois qui viennent
mais d'incarner un projet un projet de
société un objectif de redressement pour
notre pays avec une volonté d'efforts
partagés d'efficacité mais pour faire de
telle sorte que ceci puisse avoir des
résultats rapides mais en fonction de
l'objectif qui est un objectif par
rapport aux prochaines générations faire
de telle sorte que à certains égards
nous puissions retrouver des
inspirations que je qualifierais de
gauliennes et qui feront qu'une
politique n'est pas menée en fonction du
prochain sondage ou de la prochaine
élection mais pour la prochaine
génération
cela me paraît d'autant plus important
et essentiel amener que dans la
situation politique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ou
face au Sergent Garcia de l'Élysée
Zorro va revenir et
ce qu'il faut c'est que nous centrist on
ne nous prennent pas pour les Bernardo
de Zorro c'est à dire ceux qui vont être
à côté de lui et qui seront sourds pour
le soutenir ce n'est pas ça notre
volonté ce n'est pas ça notre ambition
notre volonté et notre ambition et bien
c'est de peser en tant que tel pour être
pas les supplétifs ni tes hommes et ni
des autres mais pour être ceux autour de
qui les choses vont se cristalliser pour
faire de telle sorte que nous puissions
redresser notre pays
merci cher Philippe merci
alors je revenir une dernière fois vers
la salle parce que leur tourne chacun
mon Fessy alors là-bas je vois des
jeunes femmes
et des jeunes hommes
et des hommes
vas-y Jean-Baptiste allez-y prenez la
parole de 3 et puis on vas-y bonsoir je
suis Vladimir Mendes Borgès mère adjoint
à Amiens du secteur nord
coucou Jean-Christophe
donc pour dire je suis vraiment très
très très très heureux d'être là ce soir
parce que c'est ma première université
de rentrer je suis au modem depuis le
début et c'est vraiment une un vrai
bonheur que d'être là parmi vous ce soir
attendez la suite
par contre enfin sincèrement c'est
plutôt une déception de par rapport à ce
que j'entends ce soir une déception à
plusieurs titres d'abord monsieur
arthuif lorsque vous avez terminé votre
votre propos donc avec lequel j'étais
pratiquement enfin entièrement d'accord
sur la nécessité de se ressemble de se
rassembler le la force du centre et le
pragmatisme et du centre sauf que vous
avez bien terminé en disant pour moi
l'intérêt est de rassembler la famille
centriste Amiens est une ville centriste
nous avons vu plusieurs candidats à la
présidence de l'UDI à chaque fois je
leur ai posé la question donc ils sont
pour l'instant il y en a trois qui sont
nus Amiens j'égo Fromentin et la garde
il manque monsieur Morin à venir le
premier donc à chaque fois je l'aurais
posé la question et aucun n'a été aussi
franc direct que vous le meilleur
témoignage a dit bon bah peut-être que
dans trois ans on verra ce qu'on peut
faire donc là où je suis inquiet
l'impression que c'est uniquement une
volonté de votre part mon autre étude
réside sur le une autre phrase de
Monsieur werlink donc il disait que
lorsqu'il avait été voir les Verts quand
en général c'est quand il nous invite
c'est qu'ils ne vont pas bien et bien
moi j'en ai marre que nous invite quand
ils vont pas bien c'est parce que là
c'est c'est qu'on est la cinquième roue
du carrosse et moi j'en ai marre d'être
la cinquième roue du carrosse surtout
donc j'en avais marre d'être la
cinquième roue du carrosse surtout que
là il y a pas longtemps enfin chercher à
acheter une voiture et à il y a
plus de 5e roux dans les voitures donc
c'est à dire que c'est à dire qu'on a
vraiment plus besoin de nous
et le dernier propos c'est pour
rejoindre les différentes interventions
on a beaucoup entendu il faut vous avez
répondu il va falloir on va devoir faire
mais moi ce que j'aimerais entendre
c'est pour y arriver nous devons pour y
arriver nous allons faire nous allons
faire et c'est vraiment ça que j'attends
il a raison
allez-y je ne voudrais pas être à la
place de mes enfants
c'est une phrase absolument dramatique
c'est la pire des phrases qu'on peut
entendre et on l'entend maintenant chez
beaucoup de gens les gens de 65 70 ans
qui disent je voudrais patte à la place
de mes enfants c'est dramatique moi j'ai
une peur terrible c'est qu'après avoir
épuisé tous les détails de la lutte des
classes et bien le personnel politique
des 30 dernières années va nous laisser
tranquillement rentrer dans une guerre
beaucoup plus terrible qui va être un
conflit de génération entre des rentiers
riches des gens qui ont fait carrière
dans les trentes glorieuses du moins les
années qu'on appelle glorieuses qui
n'était tout simplement que des années
de reconstruction qui n'avaient rien de
glorieuses finalement et des jeunes
paumés aussi bien chez les diplômés que
chez les gens plutôt exclus
qui vont être ahuri exaspéré d'un appel
à la solidarité interne
intergénérationnelle que les vieux vont
demander pour continuer à aller à
Marrakech trois fois par an ou avoir des
retraites confortables et moi je vais
donner non seulement
je vais donner ma voix mais aussi tout
mon appui toutes mes forces aux hommes
politiques qui vont oser entamer une
démarche de pédagogie vis-à-vis des
anciens que je respecte pour leur dire
que dans leur bonheur dans leur richesse
il y a un effet d'aubaine dont il doit
tenir compte et qu'ils doivent dans une
certaine mesure remettre une partie au
pot de manière à pouvoir prouver à des
jeunes que la France redevient et la
France et l'Europe de l'Ouest
redeviennent des terres de d'avenir pour
eux des FAR wests des Eldorado possibles
pour les jeunes
on va prendre deux dernières
interventions allez-y
bonjour Ève
le Morbihan qui vous accueille ce soir
avec plaisir
alors ici vous avez un parterre de
militants parce qu'on ne fait pas pour
les uns à 1000 km pour venir ici pour
s'opposer à
tous les leaders que nous avons sur le
plateau et ailleurs mais il faut que
vous entendiez quelque chose on vous
reconnaît comme des gens brillants comme
des gens intègres vous portez des
valeurs qui ont été portées par François
Bayrou au cours des deux présidentielles
dernière mais
entendez-nous comment nous nous devons
quand nous croisons nos voisins quand
nous allons tracter sur les marchés
qu'est-ce que nous devons dire
qu'est-ce que nous devons dire parce que
les gens nous répètent mais oui vos
idées sont très bonnes mais on votera
pas pour vous pourquoi mais parce que
vous êtes trop gentil et puis oui il est
votre programme alors moi bêtement
moi bêtement je dis bah allez sur le
site national vous verrez il y a nos
idées notre programme il y a le
programme de François Bayrou mais il est
toujours d'actualité regardez il est
complet regardez au niveau économique
regarde
ce qu'on voit aussi sur votre site on
voit des gens qui dans le petit le petit
carré qui est réservé aux états d'âme
qui vous bave dessus et personne ne
répond
et personne ne répond on se permet
d'insulter votre chef d'insulter vos
sous-chef
et
ça passe il y a pas de problème et quand
vous êtes sur les marchés mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez à nous raconter alors
comment on va faire pour notre fils qui
est au chômage quoi alors moi ce que
j'attends de vous c'est que vous vous
réunissiez je sais que vous vous emploi
du temps sont terribles et que vous nous
donniez des élégants des éléments de
langage que vous ne donniez le petit
bagage tout bête au moins le mois de ce
qu'on peut dire nous quand on descend
quand on ose quand on ose aller se faire
insulter par les gens du Front national
mais c'est un honneur
et
dernière chose je vais pas monopoliser
je me rends compte que moi qui viens
d'un milieu gaulliste où on aime les
choses un peu cadrées on est très mal
élevé et quand je me suis dans le centre
je suis arrivé je me suis trouvé très
très mal élevé parce que c'est vrai
quelque part on est trop bien élevé au
centre et c'est fini il faut maintenant
savoir taper sur la table et apporter
quelque chose alors je vous en supplie
réunissez-vous faites-nous un petit
module de langage et si vous le pouvez
déléguer un de vous un de nos
vice-présidents à être en lien direct
avec les militants qui viennent
venez venez
animer des soirées des des souper
comment on appelle ça des dînés débats
où on pourra inviter nos amis nos
voisins etc ils paieront leur place donc
ça coûtera rien au modèle il y a pas de
problème l'effet dépendront en charge
vos frais de déplacement on aura donc
des têtes d'affiches et croyez moi si on
a Marielle de Sarnez où on Jean LaSalle
bien sûr et tout vous tous il y a pas de
problème qui venait un jour à Vannes un
autre je sais pas à Lille etc animé un
dîner débat là ça marchera et ben on
viendra
c'est assez il en est ainsi décidé
Erwan
je reprends la parole je l'ai pris tout
à l'heure parce que par rapport à ta
réflexion j'ai oublié ton prénom
Vladimir et votre réflexion je il y a
des choses qui me dérangent un peu dans
ce que j'entends
déjà on est ici on peut pas leur
demander nous demander vous demander
d'avoir des réponses tout de suite là si
on avait des réponses
ben non non non
je suis désolé je suis désolé on peut
pas on peut pas faire exactement la même
chose que les autres parties que dire
que tout va être facile et qu'on va
réussir à raser gratis
mais je sais que c'est pas ça mais sauf
que attendez attendez on va le laisser
parler sauf que par rapport à ce que
vous dites par rapport à ce que vous
dites sur notre vie de de partir etc etc
moi je suis désolé ça commence aussi par
chacun d'entre nous sur les territoires
alors je sais bien c'est toujours on
veut toujours enfin voilà avec Marc on
essaye d'animer là je prends la défense
de voilà
non mais vous n'attaquez personne mais
vous dites quand même des choses qui
sont un petit peu mais ce qu'on dit sur
les marchés ce que vous dites sur les
marchés vous dites déjà que vous êtes
investi dans telle association que vous
travaillez que vous êtes en train de
réfléchir au projet pour la ville c'est
là que ça commence la politique
mais qu'est-ce que enfin je sais pas moi
alors je vais parler de moi j'étais
candidat à la commune d'à côté
mais vous êtes militante mais être
militant c'est aussi être candidat c'est
aussi faire c'est aussi d'aider les
candidats
mais
Erwan
Erwan on a entendu je pense que tout ce
qui a été dit est très important
qu'on l'entende il y a des besoins
d'avoir du matériel des choses Nathalie
est-ce que tu peux en dire un mot prends
un micro il y a besoin d'avoir des
réponses
il y a besoin d'avoir des réponses il y
a besoin d'avoir des présences sur le
terrain il y a besoin d'avoir des
implications il y a un devoir à agir il
y a une obligation d'agir et moi je
l'entends comme tel et je vous en
remercie
merci
merci tout d'abord moi pour rejoindre
Vladimir Damien et Madame qui nous
accueille ici je veux dire le plaisir
que j'ai de devenir Eva Eve de venir
à ces rencontres même si j'ai fait 1000
km je suis très très contente parce que
c'est un moment de réflexion un moment
d'échange un moment de conseil à un
moment de vérité ce que vient de dire
Ève correspond à ce que beaucoup de
militants et beaucoup peut-être de
citoyens même non militants
souhaitent peut-être avoir c'est avoir
une boîte à outils et donc quelques
éléments moi je pense que c'est c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'on mette au
point et qu'on pourra tout à fait mettre
au point on peut le faire à la fois sur
le plan européen et sur le plan national
je crois qu'il yann est prêt il m'a dit
il est prêt à le faire on en a discuté
et voilà c'est pas anniversaire mais le
voilà fin prêt pour le faire et on peut
le faire en mutualisant c'est comme ça
qu'on travaille par exemple dans la
délégation sous la conduite de Marielle
au plan européen on ne peut pas être au
four et au moulin on est chacun dans nos
domaines de compétences et ensuite nous
mutualisons nous travaillons de cette
façon là et on peut très très bien le
diffuser et le faire aussi au plan de
notre mouvement ce qui nous permet aussi
d'avoir un aller-retour et d'avoir aussi
votre ressenti parce que puisque j'ai le
micro sur la thématique de ce soir je
pense que plutôt que d'imaginer pour
apporter une réponse très concrète à la
demande de d'éléments concrets pour
reconstruire notre pays peut-être que la
méthode consiste avant tout pour nous
qui sommes justement
nature simple c'est de commencer par
écouter nos concitoyens c'est ce que
Jean a très très bien dit je pense que
notre pays est dans un tel état Yann a
utilisé le terme tout à l'heure il a dit
quand je retrouve les copains on parlait
politique on ne parle même plus
politique il a dit nous sommes fatigués
effectivement les Français sont fatigués
ils sont exténués ils ont même passé la
phase de consternation ils sont
profondément fatigués et ça c'est de
cela dont on doit partir pour pouvoir
imaginer
ce projet s'est alternative en
partageant des convictions en les en les
confrontant puisque sur l'essentiel
beaucoup d'hommes et de femmes qui ne
sont pas nécessairement politisés ont
une idée ont une intuition sur les
nécessités à faire pour notre pays nous
avons des leaders François Bayrou vous
avez vu ce qui se passe sur les
autoroutes vous avez vu ce qui se passe
sur la faire tapis vous avez on peut
multiplier à l'envie les exemples où on
voit que François avait raison avant
tout le monde donc et qu'aujourd'hui on
entend des gens proposaient des
solutions qu'il a proposé qu'il a mis en
oeuvre qu'il a donc fait plus que
suggérer puisqu'il a parfois même porté
devant le juge des dossiers qui ont
montré combien ils étaient
explosifs pourris pour certains et donc
cette intuition de l'alternative
politique nous devons la construire avec
les Français en les écoutant en allant
sur les territoires en allant auprès
d'eux en peut-être pas en marchant parce
que moi je marche beaucoup moins vite
que Marielle en plus vous avez vu que je
me casse la figure et je vous marche
beaucoup moins longtemps que Jean mais
cette intuition nous pouvons la mettre
debout la mettre en mouvement et donc
remplir concrétiser parce que le pire
aujourd'hui c'est pas la crise
économique le pire c'est même pas la
crise sociale le pire c'est la perte de
confiance et c'est ce que disait Robert
tout à l'heure c'est à dire c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de reconstruire
la la confiance et on le sent si vous
avez regardé l'émission d'hier soir ou
François était face à à la fois un chef
d'entreprise et cette salarié de de chez
doux
on le lit dans les yeux de nos
concitoyens et pas seulement moi je veux
pas distinguer entre les anciens jeunes
qui vont à Marrakech et puis les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui moi je vois beaucoup de
personnes retraitées qui vivent dans des
conditions pécuniaires qui sont
extrêmement difficiles extrêmement
difficiles encore ce matin j'ai discuté
dans ma ville avec une dame qui veut
plus mettre le chauffage en route qui se
lave à l'eau froide parce que elle veut
pouvoir
éventuellement anticiper un tout petit
peu l'avenir tant les gens
ont peur de cet avenir donc il nous
revient à nous de construire une
alternative politique en partageant nos
convictions mais en écoutant nos
concitoyens et si Marine Le Pen a cette
audience c'est en partie à cause de des
gouvernants et c'est en partie à cause
de cette perte de confiance les uns ont
clivé notre société entre les jeunes et
les anciens jeunes entre les pauvres et
les riches entre ceux qui travaillent et
ceux qui sont au chômage entre les
blonds et les bras etc entre les filles
et les garçons et puis aujourd'hui on
n'est pas dans le clivage on est dans la
démolition totale et la confusion la
plus complète tout le monde a le tournis
il y a alors les citoyens mais même les
élus je prends pour preuve la réforme
territoriale on a vaguement compris la
part du Premier ministre finalement la
date de certaines élections seraient
fixées mais on nage dans la confusion la
plus complète et notre pays est dans un
système brownien qui nous conduit dans
le fossé et si Marine Le Pen a cette
audience
évidemment elle est elle est aidée par
tous les événements qui polluent en
outre nos propres difficultés de fond
mais c'est parce qu'elle a proposé de
casser la baraque elle a proposé ça et
donc moi je pense que alors ce qu'elle
propose nous conduirait dans une
aventure absolument sombre extrêmement
dangereuse non seulement pour nous mais
pour
l'ensemble de l'Europe mais nous nous
devons proposer la rupture la proposer
sur justement un projet et une optique
qui soit construite avec les citoyens
ils n'attendent que cela ils sont
il pense les Français ils pensent ils
ont une idée et nous pouvons être
l'alternative puisque nous ne sommes ni
les uns ni les autres mais cette
alternative elle doit partir de la base
travailler sur l'économie tu l'as très
bien dit Jean on va pas continuer de
s'opposer à la mondialisation il faut
faire de la mondialisation une chance
travailler sur la République ça c'est
concret aussi pourquoi avons-nous du mal
parce que le mode de scrutin nous exclut
du champ il nous exclut du champ et
peut-être que cette déliquescence des
institutions j'en terminerai par là
parce que finalement
ça c'est un défaut des politiques je
vais quand même rendre le micro la
déliquescence des institutions elle est
due au fait qu'elles ne sont plus du
tout adaptées le mode de scrutin fait
que le pays réel n'a rien à voir avec le
pays légal rien plus rien du tout le
fossé se creuse chaque jour un peu plus
et
ce bicéphalite enfin c'est exécutif à
deux têtes vous avez vu l'exemple là de
ces derniers jours le Premier ministre
parle en premier le chef de l'État parle
derrière le peu remis au ministre alors
que la ligne si tentait qu'il y ait une
ligne devrait être donnée par le chef de
l'État donc on voit bien que ce
bicéphalisme ça va plus non plus ça ne
va plus non plus enfin c'est à discuter
peut-être ici on n'est pas tous d'accord
là-dessus mais ces institutions ne sont
plus adaptées à la vie de notre pays
est-ce qu'attendre les citoyens donc
j'aurais encore mis l'idée mais je suis
prête à travailler avec Yann sur la
boîte à outils merci merci beaucoup
Nathalie François
où est Eve
j'ai été très très intéressé par ce que
vous avez dit
et au fond que tu as un peu proche de ce
que Vladimir disait
et pour moi c'est une réflexion qu'il
faut que nous entamons alors je vais
essayer de résumer avec des mots crus
vous dites on se fait engueuler sur les
marchés
est-ce que vous connaissez un parti
politique qui se fasse pas engueuler sur
les marchés
bien
et qu'est-ce que vous faites sur les
marchés
vous tendez des tracts ou vous dites il
faut voter pour nous
c'est absolument impossible de vendre
aux gens
par une démarche marketing
ce qu'est
la vérité d'un parti politique de ses
valeurs et de ses idées
vous n'y arriverez pas les autres n'y
arrivent pas alors vous dites on se fait
engueuler sur le site on se fait traiter
de tout
ouais je me fais traiter de tout ça mais
absolument indifférent on pourrait avoir
des amis qui tapent en insultant ce qui
nous insulte on a choisi de pas faire ça
parce que Internet après des réflexions
nombreuses nous avons conclu que c'était
la liberté de parole que le regretter on
peut discuter il y a des parties dans
lesquelles il y a des modérateurs qui
coupent ceux qui vous insulte chez nous
justement non ça fait une différence moi
je vous conseille d'avoir une démarche
complètement différente je le dis
d'autant plus que à Pau on a une équipe
solide nombreuse qui est là pour une
grande part jamais en fait de
distribution de tracts modernes
voilà faites quelque chose d'autre
installez-vous sur les marchés et aider
les gens qui ont besoin d'être aidés
vous les écoutez vous prenez leurs
problèmes vous essayez de remplir leur
papier s'ils arrivent par remplir leur
papier vous leur apportez de l'aide et
du soutien et vous montrerez que
l'importance c'est parce que vous dites
c'est ce que vous êtes et si nous sommes
le parti des gens qui aident les autres
à ce moment-là on aura fait un pas
sérieux en avant n'attendez pas des
argumentaires vous-même donnez l'exemple
de ce que vous êtes ne pensez pas qu'il
existe quelque part quelqu'un qui va
vous donner le bon train pour faire ça
ça c'est la politique d'il y a 50 ans
c'est complètement fini expliqué que
vous distribuez des tracts parce que
vous êtes les plus beaux les plus
intelligents les meilleurs et même que
votre leader est le plus beau non le
plus intelligent et le meilleur ça c'est
possible mais ça n'est pas ce que les
gens attendent
sauvent dans le cœur du cœur d'une
campagne électorale présidentielle soyez
là montrez qui vous êtes
identifiez-vous et aidez les gens
écoutez-les
apportez-leur des services monter des
chaînes de solidarité vous ferez quelque
chose d'utile d'épanouissant pour vous
et que vous identifiez mieux que des
tracts c'est au moins ce que je crois
mes chers amis il est on va encore
passer deux jours ensemble donc on va
pouvoir se parler la nuit n'est pas
terminée pour ceux qui veulent continuer
après la réunion à se rencontrer à se
retrouver à parler ensemble mais il y a
un moment où il faut finir une réunion
et l'heure est assez tardive donc moi je
voudrais quand même en votre nom à tous
je pense j'espère remercier beaucoup et
Philippe folio et genre arthui qui sont
là pas seulement pour leur présence mais
aussi pour ce qui nous ont dit c'est à
dire que le chemin que nous avons initié
en construisant ensemble l'alternative
ils veulent qu'on le poursuive ils
veulent qu'on l'amplifie ils veulent
qu'on se rassemble pour peser et bien de
cela je leur dis merci en votre nom
je repasse la parole pour quelques mots
et agent et à Philippe et après
j'essaierai voilà pour ma part de faire
une toute petite conclusion cher Jean
d'abord merci infiniment nous avoir
invité ce soir
les débats au modem sont stimulants
vivifiant
et puis ce que vous voulez du concret
je mesure à quel point il faudrait qu'on
vienne plus souvent vers vous
par exemple
nous allons essayer au plan européen
d'apporter la première pierre
de ce qui pourrait être
le droit du travail européen
en imaginant un contrat d'apprentissage
qui puisse s'appliquer sur l'ensemble du
territoire de l'Union européenne et de
faciliter ainsi la mobilité des jeunes
qu'un jeune puisse aller dans un autre
pays et que l'on partage cette
conviction que l'apprentissage en effet
et sans doute l'une des voies
privilégiées pour accéder à la vie
professionnelle
ça
c'est du Congrès
alors pour le reste bon je reviendrai
volontiers si vous voulez qu'on parle de
choses plus concrètes
pour améliorer la compétitivité par
exemple des entreprises et de cesser de
croire que les autres pays de l'Union
européenne vont prendre la France pour
modèle Carrefour être costaud pour
vendre le modèle français à nos
partenaires
nos partenaires a tué fiers de ton
modèle
et rappelle-moi comment ça se passe pour
le chômage comment ça se passe pour
l'équilibre de tes comptes publics
pour l'évolution de ton endettement
public et tu voudrais nous vendre ce
modèle
sachant que si nous voulons faire
converger
les législations parce que nous avons la
même monnaie
vous savez que les l'Angleterre disait
si jamais l'Écosse prend son
indépendance
pas question quelle est la même monnaie
parce que elle aura pas les mêmes lois
que nous et quand on n'est pas les mêmes
lois quand on n'a pas une vraie
convergence fiscale sociale droit du
travail c'est très difficile de pouvoir
avoir un marché unique donc l'Europe a
des vrais des vrais progrès accomplir
c'est pour ça qu'il faut je crois maman
est un aimant cessez de l'élargir et de
de travailler pour faire converger pour
faire converger et ça va pas être simple
chez nous
au fond dans l'état où nous sommes
il faut faire une sorte de dévaluation
alors d'évaluer la monnaie c'est pas
possible puisqu'on a la monnaie unique
et c'est très bien
on pourrait dévaluer et comme on fait
les Grecs ou les Italiens ou les
Espagnols
les niveaux des salaires pas possible ça
a l'air model sont vraiment très faibles
en revanche on peut dévaluer le niveau
des charges sociales et financer
autrement la protection sociale mais
ceci est à l'autre sujet et j'aurais
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir si vous
m'invitez et j'espère que ma vitrerie
voilà en tout cas merci infiniment je
pense que
il faudra être courageux il faudra être
pédagogue nous vivons de société
complexe et c'est pas simple de mettre
sur un tract les trois ou quatre
propositions comme sur un tweet on vit
dans un monde où il faudrait tout dire
en 140 caractères et bien c'est pas
possible il faut prendre le temps
d'expliquer et il faut aussi que le
politique cesse de prendre les gens pour
des sauts avec des conventions de
langage qui sont totalement irréalistes
et qui est qui sont un manque de respect
absolu à l'égard de nos concitoyens
alors c'est chaud
de laisser peser sur le monde politique
la sphère publique une présomption de
parasitisme et il faut que les centrist
je vois les activateurs du
réenchantement de la vie politique
Philippe justement
par rapport au tout d'abord pour dire le
respect qui doit être le long train pour
vous militant qui de manière avec
beaucoup de d'humilité de manière
courageuse je veux dire ayez le courage
de porter nos idées dans des moments où
finalement c'est parfois plus facile
d'aller dans le sens du vent de la
démagogie du populisme et de tout ce que
vous connaissez et ça je crois que c'est
un élément important de rester fier et
fidèle à nos convictions bien entendu il
faut que nous puissions travailler pour
je reprends les propos de Monsieur sur
les éléments relatifs au concrets bien
sûr je pourrais vous parler si vous avez
beaucoup de temps de de la politique de
défense de la France et de la politique
de défense de l'Europe on pourrait
parler
de nos idées de nos projets en matière
de réforme territoriale autre que ceux
du gouvernement on pourrait on pourrait
parler
on pourrait parler de la vision de notre
pays qui se croit continental européenne
alors qu'elle est mondiale et maritime
et de beaucoup d'autres sujets mais
mon propos mon propos sera en termes
d'éléments de proposition c'est dire que
peut-être nous centrist nous nous
différencie rien des autres si nous
avions capacité à porter lubiaïs au
pouvoir alors je sais pas s'il y a
Béarnais ça se dit de la même façon que
chez nous
mais loubiais c'est quoi c'est le bon
sens paysan
et si une famille politique était à même
de pouvoir finalement mettre en avant
ses principes de bon sens et bien je
crois que nous serions et nous ferions
preuve d'utilité j'allais dire pour
l'ensemble de la politique française et
c'est ce défi qu'ensemble nous allons
relever modem
udi et toutes celles et ceux qui
voudront se rassembler autour de nous
pour porter cette espérance pour la
France merci cher Philippe mais je
voudrais d'un mot
vous remercier vous toutes et vous tous
vous avez vu le modèle genre c'est bien
c'est un ADN particulier c'est une
liberté vous les aviez vu dans la
campagne parce que ils étaient dans la
campagne et ils font les campagnes et on
peut les en remercier
c'était la Vienne formidable je voulais
vous dire qu'on vous aimez surtout ne
changez rien restez comme vous êtes on a
besoin de cette liberté et de votre
exigence ça c'est la première chose et
donc merci et la deuxième chose je veux
dire que non seulement nous avons la
responsabilité de continuer de
construire ce centre pour reconstruire
la France mais au fond je crois que
notre plus grande responsabilité nous
sommes les seuls les seuls qui pourront
le faire et donc qui allons le faire
nous devons demain préparer pas
seulement préparer
l'alternative et le changement dans la
France aura besoin mais nous avons
besoin de poser les conditions pour que
ce changement soit un succès pour les
Français c'est à dire que pour la
première fois depuis 30 ans la prochaine
alternance rompe avec tous les échecs
successifs que nous connaissons depuis
30 ans et ça c'est une sacrée
responsabilité et nous sommes je le
crois je le sais les seuls à pouvoir le
faire je vous remercie